♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, A FEW WEEKS
AGO, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
PUBLISHED A PIECE CELEBRATING
THE DEEP STATES, THEY TOLD US IT
WAS PROTECTING AMERICA FROM THE
HARMFUL EFFECTS OF DEMOCRACY.
IT TURNS OUT, MOST AMERICANS
DON'T LIKE BEING TOLD THEY ARE
RULED BY UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS
AND THAT THEIR VOTES MEAN
NOTHING.
NO MATTER WHAT THEY DO, NO
MATTER HOW ASSIDUOUSLY THEY
ORGANIZE, THEY CANNOT CHANGE
POLICY AT ALL.
SO EVEN AS AN ARMY OF
BUREAUCRATIC TERMITES TRY TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT, CN AND IS
BUSILY USHERING AMERICANS THEY
ARE DEFINITELY -- THERE'S NO
ESTABLISHMENT AGENDA IN
WASHINGTON, YOU'RE RACIST IF YOU
THINK OTHERWISE.
>> I THINK THERE IS THE FANTASY
THAT THERE IS THIS RESISTANCE IN
THE ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE FBI
AND THE CIA.
>> THE STATE DEPARTMENTS, AND MY
EXPERIENCE ARE NOT EXACTLY LEFT
WING OUTFIT.
>> OF COURSE, NO DEEP STATES, NO
RESISTANCE WITHIN THE
BUREAUCRACY ACROSS THE
GOVERNMENT AGENCY PUSHING
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: THERE IS NO
DEEP STATE!
THERE'S NO RESISTANCE!
EVERYTHING IS TOTALLY --
WHAT ARE YOU WATCHING?
WHAT DOES IT MEAN WHEN PEOPLE
TELL YOU TO LIES THAT ARE SO
IMPLAUSIBLE THAT THEY MUST KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW THAT THEY ARE LIES
EVEN IF THEY TELL THEM.
WHAT IS NOT ABOUT?
I TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT IT'S
ABOUT, WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING IS
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE LOSING
CONTROL.
I COULD NOT THE INTERNET, FOR
ALL THE DOWNSIDE OF THE
INTERNET, THE UPSIDE OF THE
INTERNET YOU CAN'T CONTROL ALL
THE INFORMATION ON THE INTERNET.
AVERAGE PERSON KNOWS MORE THAN
EVER BEFORE.
IF PEOPLE, LIKE THE ONES YOU
JUST ON THE SCREEN, BASICALLY A
MONOPOLY ON CONTROL OVER THE
COUNTRY FOR A VERY LONG TIME,
ALL OF US AND ARE ARE LOSING IT.
THEY'RE PANICKED.
IF THEY'RE FREAKING OUT.
IF SO THE REDOUBLING THEIR
EFFORTS TO LIE TO YOU, CLAMP
DOWN SPEECH, TO ABOVE ALL, MAKE
SURE THAT YOU SHUT UP AND STOP
ASKING ALL THESE QUESTIONS.
IT MAKES A LIVING AND IMPROVING
THE COUNTRY BY ASKING OBVIOUS
QUESTIONS AND INSISTING ON THE
ANSWERS.
JOINING US TONIGHT.
SO, YOU JUST SAW CNN ASSURING
US, SCOLDING US FOR DARING TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS A KIND OF
UNCHANGING PERMANENT AGENDA IN
WASHINGTON.
YOU LIVE IN WASHINGTON, WHAT DO
YOU THINK?
>> THERE CERTAINLY IS, YOU SEE
THIS WHAT THE DEBATE WHERE THE
PRESIDENT'S OWN POLITICAL
APPOINTEES ARE OPPOSING HIS
CAMPAIGN PROMISES THAT HE WAS
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT THE HOLD
BACK ON FOREIGN AID AND BE
SKEPTICAL OF IT.
ANDREW MCCABE IS A CLASSIC CASE,
WE HAD A DOCUMENT WRITTEN BY
ANDREW MCCABE TO COME UNDER THE
FOIA WHERE HE IS TALKING ABOUT
WEARING A WIRE ON THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE CONFIRMATION AND WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT INVOKING THE 25TH
AMENDMENT TO LALAS LAKE REMOVE
HIM.
HE
TELLS US, THERE'S NO RESISTANCE,
THEY DON'T LIKE THE REPUBLICANS
GENERALLY IN OFFICE, AND NOT THE
TYPE OF REPUBLICAN
DONALD TRUMP'S.
THEY POST POLICIES, IT MEANS
BREAKING THE LAW TO DO SO.
IN THIS CASE OF THE IMPEACHMENT,
LEAKS THAT CLASSIFY THE
INFORMATION THAT ENDED UP AND
ADAM SCHIFF'S OFFICE.
THEN HE LATER LIED ABOUT.
I JUST CANNOT BELIEVE THE
OFFICIALS ARE SO OBLIVIOUS --
WELL, I GUESS I CAN.
SO OBLIVIOUS TO THE ARROGANCE
THAT THEY EXUDE AS THEY
SUBSTITUTE THEIR OWN WILL AND
TRY TO SUBSTITUTE THEIR OWN WILL
FOR THE WILL OF THE ELECTED
LEADER OF AMERICA.
WELL, IT'S DONALD TRUMP, IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Tucker: IT'S UNBELIEVABLE,
I'M THANKFUL THAT THEY'RE NOT
REALLY SMART OR THEY BE TURNING
OUT EFFECTIVE PROPAGANDA.
AS IT IS, THEIR LIES ARE SO
TRANSPARENT THAT NOBODY IS
FOOLED.
NOBODY STUCK IN AN AIRPORT HAS
THEIR MIND CHANGED BY CNN, THANK
HEAVENS.
>> AND REMICADE IS WAITING TO
HEAR FROM THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TO WHETHER GOING TO THE PROSECUE
TO WHETHER GOING TO THE PROSECUD
FOR TIMES ABOUT THE LEAK.
JAMES COMEY STOLE TROMSO TO
TRUMP'S FBI FILE.